there's a passage in the Bible in
Ephesians Ephesians where it talks about
the armor of God and a key theme of that
is standing firm and that means standing
firmer in your faith against the schemes
of the devil and standing firm for the
truth and you you mentioned it it's not
easy it has not been easy you can only
imagine and it it I'm sure it will get
hard again I'm sure
the spiritual forces at work are
mounting an attack and I'm certain the
FBI is mounting some type of attack on
me and Steve and others for speaking out
because the like you said about Harvard
the institutional rot it is it's it's
everywhere it has been infiltrated
everywhere and so I wouldn't say it was
like a watershed moment of like
not this is the hill you know I think I
think that the hill is picked for us and
we just have to obey the Supreme
Commander uh Christ and if we don't do
that then then we will have to account
for that at the end